an update now the woman who helped pull
a little girl from a crash on interstate
15
is sharing her story this evening this
was breaking news last night three
people killed in that terrible crash
that happened
at the 95 north ramp yesterday morning
one was a child
according to a friend and posts online
one of the victims was also pregnant
the coroner has not released the
identities of the victims we do have joe
moeller joining us after speaking with a
woman who helped
save a little girl near where this all
happened joe
after watching this crash stephanie p
says she knew she needed to stop and
help now
this evening you can still see where
this crash happened along the freeway
here next to the world market center
building it's still black and there on
the concrete now watching this all
unfold stephanie p says people really
need to slow down
two people dead i couldn't rescue them
stephanie pease was driving home with
her son when a deadly crash happened in
front of her eyes on interstate 15
thursday the car was actually driving
pretty erratically
or pretty quick too and then when it hit
the truck everything spun out
literally in front of us and we just
dodged all of the debris
she could have kept driving but she
stopped to help she jumped out of her
truck and saw a man
who got out of the truck that was hit i
didn't know what he was getting in the
back seat
at first i was trying to get yell at him
to get out cause it was gonna
the flames already coming out the bottom
out of a pretty truck she figured out
the man was trying to save a child
i grabbed her and tried to get away from
the flames she put the young girl in her
car while emergency crews arrived
she shot this video shortly after that
she says the car underneath the truck
was scorched and she could not help
anyone else
she did what she could i had to i mean
you gotta help someone
and i was like i would hope somebody
would do the same for me she now has a
message for drivers
maybe slow down it is not worth it
you know use the next exit you don't
need to cut over four lanes
no life is worth you know that five
extra minutes
[Music]
now back out here live we are expected
to get the identities on monday due to
the coroner's office reduced hours due
to the pandemic
we also did find out that other car that
was involved that hit that truck
was a volvo reporting live here near
downtown las vegas joe mohler 8 news now